Om du inte är sugen på det men vill äta frukten för att det ska vara nyttigt och du ska få i det vitaminerna och sådär, då behöver du inte dölja det med socker.
Då får det kosta lite mer, men du vet att du sker i det bara bra saker och inte något som är gömt.
Make Sweden Stronger Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta men jag säger det.
Jag håller med, men vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Emma Telebond till podden Make Sweden Stronger.
Emma du driver ett bolag som heter Finest Seasoning.
Först välkommen till podden.
Kan du berätta för oss lite grann vad Finest Seasoning är?
Tack så mycket.
Finest Seasoning är, idag kallar vi oss mest Finest.
Det är ett företag som producerar, eller inte producerar, inte längre vi gjorde från början.
Men idag säljer vi torkar och frystorkade bär ut till våra matmusiker i Sverige och e-handlar.
Ja kul, vad sa du att ni producerade i början själva?
Ja men precis, vi började ju, jag började ju bolaget för fyra år sedan genom att producera granola.
Och då byggde jag upp ett litet rosteri i Stockholm där vi hade hela processen.
Så att vi producerade, vi rostade så att säga, och började även där då också packa de frystorkade bären.
Det växte vi oss ur och behövde outsourza.
Ja men även också så la vi ju ner själva rosteriet med granolan.
Så det var en anledning att vi behövde få hjälp att packa våra frystorkade och torkade bär.
Fan det är nästan lite deftigt att man får stänga ner sin egna, du vet den här lilla starten.
Var det ett svårt beslut att stänga ner det?
Jag har fått en fråga jättemånga gånger, var det ett svårt beslut, var det jobbigt, där du stod dag och natt och kömpade för?
Det var bara skönt, höj jag på förklaringen.
Det var faktiskt det, för mig var det så rätt beslut och det var känd att det var så rätt på alla sätt och vis.
Det är mitt bästa beslut jag gjort, att stänga ner det och öppna nästa lörd.
Du sa att nu kallar ni er för finest, men det heter ju Finest Seasoning.
Seasoning tolkar jag som någon sorts krydda eller liknande.
Är det för att granolan hade någon viss smak i början, eller vad kommer det fullständiga namnet från?
Nej men själva bakgrunden kring Finest Seasoning, den kom egentligen från krydder från första början.
Det var ju att jag har alltid haft ett stort intresse för kost, att få i sig rätta vitaminer och mineraler och sådär, men jag ville göra det på ett enkelt sätt.
Så då började det som att min man skämtade, kan du inte lägga dina vitaminer i din kanel på morgonen, så får du i dig allting.
Och där började en idé.
Och då var jag såhär, jag vill inte bara köra igång med krydder, utan då vill jag även kunna göra det med cash and granola, där jag tyckte det saknades på marknaden, något som innehöll väldigt mycket nötter, och har alltid varit väldigt fokuserad på att det ska vara utan tillsatt socker, och jag vill ha det så rent som möjligt.
Och då var det ett sätt att få i sig hälsosam frukost, eller kunna boosta din gröt med en bra kanel.
Men ganska snabbt märkte jag att krydderna var liksom, du köper en krydda och sen går det en månad och sen köper du en ny krydda.
Så du behöver väldigt många krydder, och det blev väldigt svårt att skata den processen.
Så det blev liksom Grönåland som satte fart från början då.
Du är kostrådgivare från starten visste du det?
Ja, eller jag har egentligen alltid jobbat med försäljning.
Så det är egentligen det som jag har gjort.
Så jag hade precis flyttat med ett svenskt bolag till Holland, för att vara med och starta upp en säljorganisation där.
Jag kom dit under pandemin så det var lock down och ganska starka restriktioner.
Så man hade tid att börja med någon idé kring någon ny affär, vad kan jag göra och då kom det här samtidigt.
Då kände jag att för att bygga ett livsmedelsbolag i Sverige behöver du ha någon trygghet inom kost.
Så då körde jag en kostrådgivning som jag pluggade under nästan ett halvårs tid på distans.
Okej, jag fattar.
Så kostrådgivningen var ett resultat av att du tyckte att det var intressant att gå in i den här branschen.
Det var inte tvärtom, men jag fattar, ja det var kul.
Nej, det var det inte.
Men man lärde sig mycket och jag är väldigt tacksam att jag tog den här utbildningen faktiskt.
Kan du berätta lite om hur man sätter igång, för på något sätt är det ju så här att rätt många e-handelsbolag jobbar ju med produkter som inte är ätbara.
Alltså, vi säljer liksom hantlar och många säljer kläder eller sånt där.
Och på ett sätt så är det klart att det kan vara problem att sourcea och det kan vara problem att sälja men men det är ändå ganska enkelt eftersom det är ju inte en produkt som någon ska äta.
Du behöver inte förvara det på något speciellt sätt.
Det gör ingenting om den får en smäll.
Alltså, sådär men jag bara intalar mig att livsmedel är jävligt mycket krångligare och att det är liksom mäckare.
Du har ett bäst fördatum, du ska liksom ha koll på någon sorts innehåll som du säger att du sa att vi vill inte ha tillsatt socker.
Men med rätt många av till exempel torkad frukt så ser man ju att de har ett litet tillskott av dextrose eller vad som helst.
Och då blir det såhär, vart ska du hitta en leverantör som inte gör det och varför använder alla det där?
Varför ska jag göra det?
Kan du inte bara förklara lite hela mäcket kring att dra igång det där med livsmedel?
Ja men jag förstod inte det när jag startade det.
Och det är jag nog glad för.
För idag hade jag kanske inte just startat ett livsmedelsbolag på grund av alla regler.
Jag tycker verkligen att det är superbra att det finns så mycket restriktioner när det kommer till livsmedel.
För det är ju mycket om man kanske följer någon profil på internet eller vad som helst som lägger upp en ny trend kring någon hälsoprodukt men egentligen finns det ingen forskning på det.
Och det är ju där du sitter och liksom, där finns ju risk om du går ut och säljer någonting som det inte finns så mycket evidens kring.
Så jag tycker det är bra att det finns.
Det är en utmaning framförallt som liten företagare.
Du betalar samma avgifter, samma kontroller om du säljer till 20 butiker eller om du säljer till 5 000 butiker.
Det blir en väldigt tajt budget när du bara säljer till de här 30 butikerna.
Men du ska ändå följa de där reglerna.
Så det har varit väldigt utmanande.
Men sen har väl också landat i att man får mycket hjälp idag.
Även om det är mycket regler de kontrollerar och det är olika revideringar och allt möjligt så får man mycket, man lär sig utav dem.
Min första som jag tänkte skulle ta två timmar tog sju timmar.
För att de någonstans känner att de inte vill sätta dit den utan de vill ju bara skydda konsumenterna.
Man har liksom fått lära sig den hårda vägen.
Då står de bakom dig och lyssnar på när du pratar nu.
Du är ändå väldigt snäll emot honom.
Ja, nej men i början tyckte jag faktiskt, då var jag såhär, varför ska jag göra det här?
Varför ska jag lägga såhär mycket pengar?
Och det står jag fortfarande fast i nu, att jag tycker det är konstigt att man ska betala såhär mycket när man bara omsätter den lilla lilla volymen.
Ju mer man har läst på, just det är mer man ser i butikerna, det här får inte stå, det här får inte stå.
För man, idag ser man det med andra ögon, och då tycker jag det är ganska, då har man lärt sig att man tycker det är ganska bra faktiskt.
Ja men jag, jag fattar, men för granolan då tillverkade du ju, ja men hemma får vi väl kalla det då, eller i alla fall på egen hand då.
När du gick över här till torkad frukt som är, för det är väl hela din affär idag, det är väl, ja, hur skedde den sourcingen och hur drog du igång det?
Nej men jag hade ju redan ganska mycket butiker som jag såg det till.
Och mina butiker hade ju, det är ju jag som har sålt in till alla butiker.
Så det var ju, jag hade hjälp på rosteriet, jag hade anställda och så där.
Annars var det ju bara jag som var ut och träffade dem.
Så liksom ICA-handlarna och de här vart väl lite som mina kollegor.
Då var det egentligen dem som sa till mig att kan du inte testa att ta fram frystökade hallon?
Och då hade vi redan hallon i vår granola.
Så det var ett ganska enkelt steg för mig att testa att packa i den.
I en hallon på sig i stallet.
Och märkte jag att om den här kommer ju väldigt mycket mer ådra än vad det gjorde på granolan.
Vi säljer väldigt mycket mer bara på väldigt kort tid.
Och sen så var det en annan ICA-handlare som tipsade mig om mango precis när den här IPA kom.
Och då hade jag även där leverantörer.
Då blev det också att det blev väldigt tydligt att det är det här vi säljer, det är det här som efterfrågas på marknaden.
Så att alla kostnader som var kring kontrollmyndigheterna på en egen livsmedelsproduktion, till personal, till hyra, till att jag var där nästan dag och natt, så blev det ganska tydligt att det inte är värt det här längre.
Och då hittade jag leverantörer som kunde packa det åt mig.
Då var det på bara två, tre månader ungefär så hade vi liksom växlat om, stängt granolan och outsourcert hela produktionen.
Och på den tiden så bara steg liksom omsättning.
Så därför blev det väldigt positivt att hela tiden göra det här skiftet.
Jag fattar, all fan vad nice.
Hur är sitt setup idag?
Nu köper ni in från, jag tror jag läste checken till exempel.
Löser de allting med förpackning och sånt så att du bara får färdiga pallar eller hur funkar det liksom?
Idag har vi köpt in påsarna hos en leverantör som själva tomma påsarna.
För även där är det väldigt mycket regler kring vad du får ha för påsar.
Herregud, ja såklart.
Den måste vara love-testad och den måste vara godkänd för att ha olika frukter och sådär i.
Och ännu mer när det är torkat utan tillsatt socker, för det är kortare hållbarhet och sådär.
Så det gör vi och sen skickas det till...
Vi har haft tur att ha haft ett tyst företag som vi har jobbat med sen början som levererar nötter till oss från början till Grunåland.
Så de sköter egentligen på torkade frukt.
Och sen har vi haft Polen som nu även flyttas till Riga som sköter all våran frystorkning.
Så de gör det, frystorkar processen och packar det i de påsar som vi har skickat till dem.
Och sen går det till ett lager och sen går det ut i matbutikerna.
Jag fattar, fan det sker ändå x antal steg på den här vägen.
Det är fascinerande i sig men jag är fascinerad av en annan grej.
Du nämnde att mango liksom var en grej och jag tycker att jag ser mango överallt.
Är det någon sorts, är det en trend på riktigt?
Har mango eller är det bara att jag har börjat äta mango därför så ser jag det eller?
Nej men alltså det är, generellt så tänker jag att torkat frukt har blivit en trend att äta.
Varför har det blivit en trend?
Men jag tror att det är liksom i samband med att vi har blivit ett helg, alltså folk har liksom, vi har ett hälsofokus idag, folk vill äta nyttigt, folk tittar lite på vad de stoppar i sig och så där, man vill inte bara äta ett kex utan då tar eller en bars alltid med en massa sockerit och då kanske de vill ha en känslig nyttighet att äta frukt istället, som mellanmål eller ge till sina barn.
Men varför äter folk torkar?
Vad är det för fel med, fan, åt inte alla vi människor typ banan och äpplen när vi var små?
Är våra barn bortskämda som får mango till mellanmål?
Det tror jag nog, absolut det tror jag verkligen.
Men jag, ja, varför har vi blivit torka?
Jag tänker att det är mer tillfredsställande.
Ett äpple är slut på några minuter, medan du kan sitta och äta, det blir mer ett snacks.
Man ser ju idag i alla livsmedelsbutik att just snacks växer otroligt.
Det är nya leveratörer hela tiden på just snacks.
Så jag tror att det är det här snacksandet som vi har blivit en grej bland oss.
Framför allt kanske då svenskar att ha någonting att snacksa på i väskan eller framför TV eller det här.
Okej, så nu bara spekulerar jag.
Är det så att torkad frukt ska på något sätt ersätta godis, snarare än att det ska ersätta mellanmålet?
Är det den trenden vi rör oss mot?
Jag tror det är den trenden.
Sen tror jag att det är många som har det även som mellanmål.
Innan man går till gymmet eller efter man har gått till gymmet, att man även tar det där.
Men jag tror framförallt att det är det här snackshandet, som man vill ta bort godiset.
Vi vill äta mycket söt idag.
Och jag märker att mycket produkter innehåller söt på olika sätt, eller sötningsmedel.
Många vill åt det här söta, så jag tror att det där av frukten kommer in nu.
Vad är problematiken med att, för du sa att du inte vill ha socker i, och vi tar mango som exempel.
Alltså, spelar det egentligen någon roll om man lägger i 1% socker?
Jag vet inte hur mycket socker man lägger i i en vanlig sockermango då, men om jag lägger i 5% socker och mangoen då håller i ett år eller längre, inte är det positivt.
Spelar det någon roll egentligen?
Vad är det?
Du får gärna försvara till ditt beslut.
Hela min idé kring att jag vill ha utav tillsatt socker är för att jag har en pappa som är diabetiker.
Så för mig har det varit viktigt, och jag har det i släkten, så för mig har det varit viktigt att du ska kunna snacksa men du ska inte behöva luras med att det ska finnas socker i det.
Utan som frukten har blåst väldigt tydligt för oss hela tiden att vi vill inte tillsätta socker i går.
Det blir mycket billigare absolut, men vi har någonstans också hittat våra kunder som gillar oss för att vi har hög kvalitiv av produkter.
Vi väljer att köpa in från en och samma leverantör.
Det ska inte komma från Kina, Ryssland, Brasilien, utan det ska vara en trygg produkt att gå och köpa.
Då vill jag även känna att jag tror då kanske hellre att gå under en kanelbull när du är sugen på det, men vill äta frukten för att det ska vara nyttigt och du ska få i det vitaminerna och sådär.
Då behöver vi inte dölja det med socker, utan då vill jag hellre att det får kosta lite mer, men du vet att du får i det bara bra saker och inte något som är gömt.
Hur mycket påverkar sockret i hållbarhet?
Hur mycket snackar vi ett halvår till ett år?
Vad är det som inte fattar detta?
Det är ungefär ett halvår extra om du har haft socker i.
Vissa är till och med upp till nästan ett år.
Framförallt om vi kollar på de här frystorkade produkterna, det hade varit socker i det också då, det hade ju hållit väldigt mycket längre.
Men där är det ju absolut en kostnadsgrej kring att det håller längre och hållbarhet.
Men största skillnaden är ju utfyllnaden.
När du fyller ut det med socker så blir det en billigare produkt.
Och du behöver inte en lika bra mango, utan du kan ta en halvbra mango som kanske redan är övermogen eller som inte är, liksom, den är inte topp.
Och så tillsätter du socker, då blir den bra.
Så du döljer liksom produkten med socker.
Jag fattar, det blir någon sorts smak maskerade på något sätt.
Det här var spännande.
Ja, men vi måste liksom ha toppmangon till exempel, eller toppananasen.
Så du behöver väldigt mycket mer frukt när du ska göra utav tillsatt socker.
Vad är det som gör, och jag menar inte är det en produkt specifikt, utan torkad frukt.
Det jag är väldigt fascinerad över är nu, jag var på en mack här, vi var uppe på ett bygg i Stockholm och så var det en av mina kollegor som såg mango, det är därför jag har fastnat på mango.
För då var han såhär, ja titta torkad mango, det ska jag köpa och då köpte alla torkad mango.
Så skulle jag bara betala det med företagskortet och jag tänkte, ja en sådan där påse, vad är det i de liksom 30 gram mango eller någonting?
Och den kostar typ 45 spänn eller någonting.
Vad är det som gör att det är så fruktansvärt jävla dyrt att köpa, för jag köper vanlig mango och ibland köper jag den för liksom 10 spänn styck eller 15 spänn styck när det är rea liksom.
Men hur fan kan 30 gram kosta?
Det borde vara billigare när den är torkad, intalar jag mig.
Nej men alltså till, alltså ungefär till ett kilo frukt eller bär eller så, ungefär till ett kilo så behöver du nästan 5-10 kilo färsk frukt.
Och det är ju för att du suger ju vätskan ur den.
Så att det att du behöver, visst köper du mango precis i säsong, då kan du köpa den billigt.
Men om du köper en mango och vet att det här är egentligen 5-10 gånger mer än vad det är i den där påsen, det är det som gör att det blir dyrt och sen är det processen.
Och ju precis som man var inne på, ju mer, ja, som vi då som inte har något tillsatt socker, då är det en helt annan process.
Den måste gå till väldigt långsamt, den är väldigt mycket kål, så att det inte är någonting.
Så det är själva processen som också är kostsam när man torkar.
Ja, så det är egentligen det.
Så att jag hade också önskat att det var mycket billigare, men det är tyvärr alltså.
Ni har gjort lite produktutveckling genom åren.
Jag ståkade er ett Instagramkonto lite grann och så såg jag vad ni har haft tidigare, vad ni sålde.
Då sålde ni också banan till exempel, någon sorts kakaodaddlarvariant.
Vad är det som gör att ni har tagit bort vissa produkter?
För jag ser fortfarande banan till exempel säljas i butiker som är tålkad.
Varför har ni valt det ni har valt, och varför inte bara bibehålla allt?
Nej men, just bananchips har vi ju kvar faktiskt.
Jaha okej, det är dåligt av mig.
Nej men...
Jo det är okej, det är dåligt av mig.
Vi ville ha gjort om påsen, så vi hade en liten innan, men nu är det en stor pås.
Så iskakaodaddlar var ju vår granola, så där blev det väldigt tydligt att det var granolan varför vi avslutade den.
Sen, just de torkade frukterna, det har vi idag egentligen kvar alla, som vi har börjat med.
Sen är det, ibland gör vi lite tester, att testa en produkt som vi släppte nu, en limited edition här över jul, en Ingefära mörk choklad.
Det är ju en liten tanke att vi testar det för att se, ska vi även ha till exempel ett snacksben med lite det här om du vill ha, det här söta också.
Så mycket kan man ju göra, vi har haft möjlighet att släppa det mindre, vi behöver inte köpa in jättemånga påsar, utan kan testa oss fram lite, innan vi går på den stora beställningen.
Men varför tog ni bort choklad och dadla?
Jag hängde inte med på var det bara fattig.
Det var kakodaddla vi smakade granola.
Så vi tog ju bort all granola när vi stängde vårt roste i, för att granolan var för komplex till att outsourca.
Det var väldigt svårt att få fram just den vidbira året.
Och i och med att bärarna och frukten hade tats fart så mycket, så valde vi att stänga ner hela rosteriet.
Därför la vi ner all granola.
Så det var för att kunna skala upp bolaget egentligen.
Yes.
Hur ser er modell ut?
Hur mycket är det att ni säljer via e-handel?
Hur mycket går i butiker?
Hur mycket går via online?
Hur mycket säljer ni via Apohem och liknande?
Hur ser liksom businessen ut?
Vi säljer inte speciellt mycket på vår egen e-handel.
Det är inte där vi drar vårt trafik.
Utan vi har ju egentligen varit störst på Iska och Coop och Hedmiköp och sådär.
Men sen sista, jag skulle säga halvåret, så har ändå apotekkedjorna, med Apohem och de här, blivit nästan våra 50 procentiga kund skulle jag säga.
Så det är ungefär 50-50 på butiker och e-handlarna som apotekkedjorna idag skulle jag säga.
Jag har hört i andra poddar ibland när de är med i, alltså när de finns på sådana nätapotek och liknande.
Det verkar vara ganska typ högt tryck på att man ska rabattera eller att man ska rea ut.
Är det något du har upplevt och hur står man emot det eller behöver du stå emot det eller hur tänker du kring det?
Så är det verkligen att de vill ha mycket rabatter, de vill köra mycket kampanjer.
Man vet ju själv när man går in och googlar efter en produkt eller om jag har sett mig själv att jag går in och googlar efter någonting så kollar jag runt på apotekskedjorna och okej, där var rabatter jag köpte därifrån.
De satsar väldigt mycket på att vi ska enligt mig trycks våra priser ner väldigt mycket.
Men någonstans har jag också landat i att de kör ju också, det är en väldigt bra kanal att synas på.
De hittar våra produkter för att sen kanske hitta den i matbutiken.
Man har fått väga det att ja, marginalen blir sämre men det blir också en bra marknadsföringssida att finnas på.
Jobbar matbutikerna på samma sätt?
Är de också på och pushar?
Det är lite olika.
Vissa sker ju allt centralt på kostnaderna så då blir det ju inte bara en butik, utan då sätter ju liksom, om man är en som Coop till exempel, de sätter själva sitt pris, då blir det bara en person som jag egentligen får handla med och så sätts det ju hela Sverige egentligen.
Medan Ica, absolut men det är mer att man tar kampanjer beroende på vilken position i butiken man vill ha, vad man vill synas någonstans.
Och då kan man sänka lite, om man ska få en bättre yta och så där i butiken, så sänker man lite ibland.
Vad är den bästa ytan?
Är det ögonhöjd eller är det strax under ögonhöjd för att man ska upplevas som att det är rätt beslut?
Nej men det är ögonhöjd, gärna lite åt höger sida och det är gavlar, det är ju liksom det bästa för våra produkter, att finnas på gavlar.
Ja just det, ni vill finnas typ vid kassan?
Ja, eller vi vill hänga tydligt på en sida så att man ser våra produkter, då säljer det ju absolut som mest, än att vi bara finns i hyllan.
Ni har ganska stora påsar, jag kollar mango här, fan vad jag fastnar på mango.
Vi kan ta någonting annat så jag inte bara pratar om mango.
Vi kan ta kiwi i våra senaste.
Ja, ni har kiwi.
Du verkar ha typ 300 grams påsar som någon sorts halvstandard eller vad vi ska säga.
Det är väl ganska stort förtorkad frukt eller?
Är det medvetet eller är det?
Inte från början var det inte det.
Men det hamnade för att det skulle vara en liknande påsar som granolan.
Men idag har vi, vårt är ju en lite mer stor pack som vi köper hem.
Vi hamnade inte riktigt där vid snackset, men det är också för att skulle vi ha exakt samma stor, liksom den andra mangon som är med socker, då ser, då kollar man mycket mer på priset.
än att nu har vi en större påsar, det är en stor pack.
Man köper hem den för helgen eller för veckan.
Då kan vi också, om vi hade haft 30 gram eller 40 gram, då blir vi helt plötsligt lite dyrare mot, alltså mycket dyrare mot kund än den som har massa socker i.
För att alla vänder inte på att se att vi inte har tillsatt socker i våra produkter.
Så därför har vi valt en stor pack av produkterna.
Och sen är det också på grund att det är en väldigt utmaning på de torkade frukterna, att packa dem i mindre påsar.
Och det är för att de är väldigt klippiga, alltså vårat är ju nästan som en färsk mango.
Har du socker så blir de inte klippiga eller klistriga.
Så våra är, ja, därför måste vi packa dem i såna stora för att vi ska kunna lägga i dem.
Jag fattar.
Allt packas för hand också.
Hur sticker man ut, du sa, ja men ni kör ju någon sorts stor pack, sådär, men hur sticker man ut inom det här?
Det finns ju x-antal, liksom produkter.
Gör ni någon marknadsföring, gör ni någonting så att folk ska känna till det förutom när de går in i affären?
Vad är er sätt att synas?
Ja men är vi med på olika event, och är vi med på olika, vi är oftast med på olika tränningsevent för att synas.
Vilken sorts event, vad handlar det här om?
Det kan vara på ett gym, att det är någon som har något tränningsevent, antingen som nu i veckan ska vara på Nordic Wellness och ha ett litet event, och då är det ofta där vi syns.
Vi syns ofta i de ställen där folk har ett hälsotänk, folk är hälsomedvetna.
Då försöker vi rikta marknadsföringen ditåt.
Sen marknadsför vi oss mycket att vi inte stoppar något socker i.
Sen har vi ju stukit ut, om man kollar bara i en butik, så har vi också, om man tänker i mangoer, väldigt färgglada påsar, det är mycket färg och så där.
Vi har ju försökt att hålla ner det lite och bli mer, kännas också det här, lite mer premium, lite lyxigare, genom att bara ha en clean, dit påse.
Så där försöker vi väl också sticka ut lite med brandingen.
När vi sitter och pratar nu, jag är också gammal, jag kanske ska säga det att jag har läst idrottsvetenskapligt tre år på universitetet och har givetvis också läst mycket kost och sånt där men, jag jobbade som viktminskningsrådgivare i flera år och också inom kost och sånt där och när man pratade om frukt så fick man alltid den här kontringen att ja men frukt har ju massa fruktsocker i sig och har du torkad frukt så har du ju en ganska en ganska hög, alltså kalorinhåll per hundra gram och liknande.
Har du upplevt någon sån problematik i er marknadsföring?
Att ni marknadsföringar som liksom nyttiga och då får ni alltid dem.
Ja men vadå det här är jättemycket socker?
Vi har inget tillsatt socker, förstår du vad jag är ut efter det här?
Ja, precis som du säger, vi träffar ju och säljer våra produkter till redan medvetna kunder.
De vet liksom vad det är de köper.
Så självklart så möter vi det.
Men någonstans landar jag också, eller har vi ofta att vi kan landa i att det bästa jag vet, jag har ju flera syskon barn, att liksom veta när de vill ha snacks på lördagkvällen, att de vill ha frystakade hallon och sitta och äta det istället för godis eller vad som helst.
Då känner jag att då har jag gjort någonting bättre än att de stoppar sig i, även om det blir socker i bären, så får du även i dig nyttiga vitaminer och mineraler än någonting som bara är framställt.
Så jag tycker ofta att man kan, sen tror jag på ett balans hela tiden, du kan inte, men som jag nämnde om min pappa som är diabetiker, han kan inte stoppa i sig en påse mango såklart, men han kan fortfarande äta två tre skivor med gottsamvete än att kanske ta den här.
Nu är han väldigt noga och sådär, men han skulle ju inte ta mangel med socker till exempel, med extra socker.
Klart märker man det, men jag tror att vill man väl äta någonting som är lite nyttigare, så tycker inte jag att det ska döljas med annat socker, då tror jag mer på att undar det är din knedbulle eller din chokladbulle.
Men jag tror Delicato gjorde någon sån reklam någon gång där det stod typ 100% onyttigt eller något sånt där.
Alltså det är fan onytt if you own it typ.
Verkligen.
Men är det så, har ni riktat er, hur ser redan marknadsföring ut och vad är det för känsla ni försöker tagga in i?
Är det den här, ni filmar en film på banen som sitter i soffan och så sitter de och trycker ostbågar och så kommer upp en stor text där det står typ 900 ingredienser, köp allon med en.
Ja men precis.
Bra tips.
Det är mitt största problem som jag tog in torkade frukterna och frystorkade bärorna, så vi börjar satsa på det 100 procent, har egentligen varit att klara av att leverera beställningar.
Vilket har gjort att jag hade velat lägga mycket mer på det, på pengar och tid och på marknadsföring och jobba med det mer.
Men vi försöker fortfarande mest klara av att leverera den volym som vi får in varje månad.
Sen är målet det här året att lägga mer pengar på just annan marknadsföring och mer än att bara synas på ställen där det är event.
Så det är mer där vi lägger tiden på att finnas på event där folk tränar.
Vad är den stora problematiken där, att kunna leverera?
Är det att det inte finns tillräckligt med mangosar i världen?
Eller är det att ni inte har likviditeten att köpa in?
Eller är det att de inte klarar av produktionen?
Vad är flaskhalsen någonstans?
Flaskhalsen är ju att det har gått ganska snabbt.
För mig som innan satt själv med eget kapital och försökte laborera med att jag fick in pengarna från ICA eller Coop eller om 30 dagar eller 15 dagar var det kvar.
Men jag ska ju också köpa in nya varor så att det ska hamna på ett lager.
Så det är ju likviditeten som har varit det utmanande.
Så det är ju ibland såklart problem, men framförallt frystorkat.
Jag skulle inte säga att det är torkare.
Men frystorkat kan vara, eftersom vi bara köper in från ett land.
Hade vi haft tio länder hade det varit lättare också.
Utmaningen är att hinna få in pengar innan jag kan beställa in nya varor.
Och att man får ordrar som vi inte har varit beredda på.
Innan har vi kanske sålt det här på tre månader.
Plötsligt så är det en kund som beställer hela vårt lager.
Där är utmaningen.
Visst tog du in ett par investerare här för inte så jättelänge sen?
Var det det som var den stora anledningen eller tycker du om dem på riktigt?
Jag tycker om dem också.
Jag satt i ett läge ganska exakt ett år sen där jag började märka att vi inte hade så många frukter, men de frukter vi hade började ta fat och det var mycket större ådrar som jag skulle täcka med eget kapital.
Då kände jag någonstans att nu sitter jag i ett läge där antingen kommer jag inte klara av, för att varannan månad levererade vi och varannan månad kunde jag inte leverera.
Det pågick så under tre månader.
Då kände jag att vi har fler ådrar här.
Jag tror att nu har vi verkligen skalat upp bolaget, vi har en ny setup och det är dags för mig att gå runt och pitcha in det här.
För att jag behöver någon som kommer in och...
Ja, jag kände väl också att jag behövde någon lite mer operativt, som kunde komma in med lite kunskap.
Framför allt var det för att jag behövde in pengar i bolaget.
Är detta ditt första bolag?
Eller första riktiga bolaget, vad jag ska kalla det.
Ja men precis, där.
Hur började du när du skulle pitcha det?
Du gick ut på gatan eller vart hittade du folk som var intresserade?
Jag hade ju under de här åren, ändå sista i alla fall året ska jag säga, att jag hade väl ändå varit utelit och mätverkat och varit på ställen, som jag tänkte att här, men där andra entreprenörer rörde sig.
Och började då egentligen ta kontakt med folk som jag visste hade kontakter.
Som jag tänkte att, frågade vad med att jag fick bjuda ut på en kaffe, ta en lunch, och varit nyfiken på dem om de visste någon som kunde vara intresserade.
Och då träffade jag en kille som jag hade träffat på ett nätverk någon gång.
Jag började förstå att jag faktiskt har något riktigt bra här.
Man började bygga lite, från att man satt där med fakturer, som var bara hur ska jag lösa det här, till att man faktiskt började förstå att vi har ett väldigt positivt problem egentligen.
Så då fick jag in lite folk som visade intresse, och som la lite bud på att gå in i bolaget.
Men sen så träffade jag en kille på en kaffe som jag bara kände ganska snabbt.
Han förstår grunden i det här hälsosamma.
Han är själv väl en elitfotbollspelare.
Vi båda klickade kändes det som.
Så då valde jag att de hade haft kontakter med lite runt om, de backade lite och så valde jag bara att fokusera på han och en kille till då som gick in tillsammans.
Får man fråga hur mycket de, dels om du vill avsvära någon sorts summa, men också hur stor del av bolaget de köpte in sig.
De gick in på en värdering på nio miljoner, så vi gjorde en ny emission.
Och så gick de in med runt en miljon.
Tillsammans.
Jag hade väl hoppats på bättre, men jag var också, det vill jag med ju alltid när det är ens egna lilla startup, men samtidigt valde också den ena killen att gå in operativt en hel del.
Vilket har varit det som jag kände att det är verkligen värt det att få in de här.
De sitter med bra kontakter, för jag tror att vi ändå snart kommer att göra en ny emission.
Får man fråga hur 2025 har gått här, för ni har vanligt bokslut, vad handlar ni på 2025?
Vi kommer ju sakta, 2025 var ju samma där, jobbigt ett halvår där vi inte levererade någonting.
För de kom in här i somras då, eller efter sommaren som allt helt har varit klart.
Okej, de har varit med i fyra månader typ.
Men trots det så har vi ändå dubblat omsättningar från föregående år.
Så jag är ändå, med att inte kunnat leverera så är jag ändå hyfsat nöjd.
Så 3,2 laddar vi på.
De här pengarna som du fick in, gick de direkt till en stor order mot fabrikerna?
Hej, nu ska vi ha mer grejer.
Är det så det fungerade eller har du portionerat ut det?
Ja, absolut.
Det har varit att kunna köpa in.
För jag hade ju inga varor i princip.
De var utöpa från ICA-butiker till ett annat lager och påsar som vi lagehållde.
Så det gick direkt till att köpa in.
Att hela tiden kunna ha varje månad.
Det har tagit nästan, vi sitter fortfarande och ligger efter med det här.
Jag hoppas nu det här första kvartalet att det ska börja ordna upp sig.
Men också att handla ner priserna.
Så att du skulle få bättre marginaler var ju också ett stort fokus.
Att köpa in större stödrar.
Och sen har det även faktiskt nu gått till att lägga pengar på en byrå som också har nu precis tagit fram nya logga och nya påsar som kommer att släppa under våren.
Inom har vi gjort allt som design själva.
Vad är det som gör att du inte har kollat på andra finansieringsmöjligheter, eller använder du olika kreditar och liknande tjänster, eller har det bara inte funkat?
Jo men precis när jag startade företaget, så vi startade ju också precis efter pandemin.
Så då tog jag det som ett första lån, men märkte ganska snabbt att det är så otroligt höga räntor.
Och just då hade jag möjligheten att gå in med dem själv, så då ganska snabbt avslutade jag det och gick in själv med pengar.
Jag känt att, alltså jag sålde min lägenhet, gick in med egen peng och de grejerna.
Till slut så kände jag nog så här, nu vill jag nog inte ta den här, jag kan inte ta mer risker själv.
Även om man tar risker hela tiden, men mer de här ekonomiska riskerna.
Och att det var, jag behövde känna, jag tänkte så här, ska jag ta något mer, något banklån eller någonting.
Men jag kände att nu är det dags för mig att ska jag få en värdering, en första värdering på bolaget här och få in någon lite operativt.
Så kändes det som om det var väldigt läge att kunna visa på ådra som jag inte kan leverera.
Så det var med att jag kände att det här blir nog första steget nu att ta in en investerare.
Vad är det operativt som har saknats?
Vad är det du fokuserar på?
Vad är det du känner att det här har legat lite efter?
När man gör intensivt allting själv, från logistik till att sälja till att, ja, sen har jag haft min man som har varit med hela tiden, Stöttning, och liksom är delägare också i bolaget, men han är inte operativ.
Så har det väl varit med att man, någonstans så släcker man ju mest bränder hela tiden.
Det är klart liksom konstant, nu måste jag läsa det här, nu måste jag läsa det här, nu måste jag läsa det här.
Så att bara hitta någon att både bolla med, men också att kunna hitta lösning inom logistiken, som kan säga till mig, nu tar vi tag i det här, eller nu gör vi det här.
Så jag tror mycket var ju ett bollplank och de som kommer in i bolaget också och tror på det, men som också kan vara drivande i nya frågor.
För mig blir det mycket att jag kör på mitt, och försöker lösa det och släcka det.
Men om de kommer in med nya ögon, så har de nya idéer som har varit väldigt värdefullt.
Att dra igång nya projekt och det friar tid hos dem själv.
Vad tror du om 2026?
Hur kommer det gå?
Vad kommer gå bra och vad kommer vara svårt?
Målet det här året är verkligen att kunna alltid ha varor på lager.
Men vi vill väl hela tiden, vi vill ju såklart växa som alla vill tänker jag.
Men vi vill någonstans också växa.
Du var ju besviken här med dubblering förra året.
Hade du varit besviken om du dubblade igen?
Eller är det tillräckligt stort nu för att du hade varit glad?
Ja men jag hade varit glad om vi dubblade igen.
Det hade jag varit.
För någonstans vill vi ändå, ja men vi behöver inte växa jättesnabbt direkt.
För det gör också att det blir jobbigt ekonomiskt.
Men en dubblering hade jag verkligen velat.
Är det någonting annorlunda i fokuset i år jämfört med tidigare eller kommer ni att plöja på de här kanalerna och bara få bolaget att rulla i sin back-end så att säga?
Nu blir det större volymer och sådär så nu är det verkligen viktigt för oss att vi knyter an till våra leverantörer som vi har, att det är väldigt viktigt att de kan leverera i tid.
Nu sitter vi mycket, vi åker och besöker dem för att få in bra avtal med dem på plats så att vi inte sätter oss i de här sitsarna som vi har gjort det här året, så att vi inte kan leverera.
Så det är mycket fokus på att få hela logistiken och att kunna leverera som är målet.
Men sen ser jag väldigt mycket fram emot att släppa en helt ny logga, en helt nya påsar, när faktiskt folk som är riktigt duktiga på det har satt sig in.
För att det är ju någonstans, det ska ju också, vi vill ju såklart att det är ett sätt för produkten att öka försäljningen också.
Att det lockar när man är i butiker.
Är du inte rädd att folk ska inte känna igen er, att det blir såhär, nu gick de här corporate också, från att...
Men jag är inte så, precis som när vi stängde när Rostedet, jag är inte så rädd av mig tror jag, utan jag tänker nog bara att det här blir nästa steg, det här är nästa steg i utvecklingen.
Så jag tror snarare att nu kommer vi hitta nya kunder kanske, och fler kunder.
Emma jag håller alla tummar för er, det ska bli kul att se er produkter i någon affär, så ska jag dyka upp där och köpa en stödpåse.
Ja men underbart.
Det blir ett stort packmango.
Stort tack för att du var med i podden.
Tack så mycket.
Men varför äter folk torkar?
Vad är det för fel med...
Fan, åt inte alla vi människor typ banan och äpplen när vi var små?
Är våra barn bortskämda som får mango liksom?